so yeah it's just building off that
point do you think sometimes and this
father's goes to you as well there's a
need for fatigue amongst two parties
that there has to be a realization that
victory cannot be won at that point they
began to reach out and dialogue along
the entire way is very good but only
until that realization has had by both
sides well that dialogue come to
fruition I think this is what he was
saying how it really is that yeah that's
true but you can't afford shorten the
period before you define exhaustion you
see me but I think I think in terms of
the contribution of the religious world
to this there is something else that
needs to be said from within prophetic
voices and I was quoting to you last
night somebody who went to see the
leadership of the republican movement 50
years ago when there was a kind of the
first round of what we called the border
campaign and he was saying to them even
if you did achieve the reunification of
ireland by force there would still
remain the moral and spiritual questions
as to how this was achieved and I you
know I think we have to look beyond they
sort of let it go if we are serious
about giving moral leadership within our
work we have to ask these other
questions so that for instance I I keep
saying to my friends from the Protestant
unionist community actually I have no
theological difficulty with us being at
a united Ireland or in a partitioned
Ireland what I want to know is what kind
of society is that the people are
fighting for I want to know what are the
values upon which this new Ireland is
going to be built whether it remains in
two parts or one those are the issues
those are the questions of we as
spiritual leaders need to be asking we
should have no particular interests as
to whether it's going to be part of
united kingdom or part of a united I'm
what we want to know is what kind of
society are you wanting to create we
just just a footnote on fatigue during
the war in former Yugoslavia it was
basically said by the third party well
they're engaged in this bloodletting
will have to let him do that for a while
and when it's all settled then they can
come and do something about it and it
can be a kind of very cynical way to
approach the situation and so it's not
only the two parties are dehumanizing
each other by the violence but the third
party is dehumanizing both of them
additionally right so so I think they
have regard against you've got both to
be wise when you step in but guard
against the too quick of a cynicism
about the situation and how quickly you
when do you need to step in Israel Rob